we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P Speaking of Chris
Christie and Joe Biden here's a caller
asking about exactly those two people
David
do you think that Chris Christie would
beat Joe Biden
and my next question would be do you
think Chris Christie
if he did win the nominee
would you start going
anti-anti woke crap too
okay so two questions there if it were
Christy versus Biden does Christy have a
shot second question if Christy became
the nominee would he go anti-woke let's
answer the second one first because it's
simpler the anti-woke stuff is more
useful within the Republican primary
than in the general election why because
most of the country actually agrees with
the quote woke side of most issues so if
Chris Christie doesn't go anti-woke
while running in the primary he is not
going to go anti-woke as a general
election candidate that I am confident
in the first question if the matchup
were Christy versus Biden in November of
2024 could Christy win I believe the
answer is yes I believe that if Maga was
soundly defeated if Trump really
crumbles and what I mean by that is he's
indicted a third time it becomes
absolutely impossible to even be out on
the campaign Trail because he's just
busy with three different criminal
defenses Republicans abandon him imagine
they select Chris Christie I believe
that that this would actually create a
Resurgence among the Republican
electorate where all of these folks who
have been dissuaded from even
participating because they're disgusted
with Trump or they just think Trump is
the wrong direction for the party I
believe all of those folks would get
engaged I believe also that there are
some people who voted for Biden in 2020
because they were so disgusted with
Trump who if there was a reasonable
Republican would actually go back to
voting Republican and so I'm not here to
tell you Christy would definitely beat
Joe Biden but if Trump is running even
with Biden I do believe that Chris
Christie has a solid shot of defeating
Biden in a general election I'm not
hoping for that I'm answering the
caller's question we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today we're going to
talk about the coming heat wave in Texas
are they actually prepared for it this
time we will talk about Cornell West now
after announcing that he's running as a
People's Party candidate also seeking
the green party nomination I'm going to
be honest with you it's all a complete
and total mess and we will give you the
latest not so good news about Tesla's
self-driving system which I have tested
out myself by the way all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
get instant access by signing up at
joinpakman.com